At this point in the course, you've
probably realized that sometimes when
you try something in code,
it just doesn't work the first time.
These errors are called bugs, and
Carl has thought a lot about bugs, and
how to get rid of them.
>> You know, Andy, writers spend
a lot of time proofreading, and
scientists spend a lot of
time checking their results.
But it was a surprise to early
programmers that debugging was
going to be a thing.
Maurice Wilkes, the Cambridge physicist
who built one of the first computers,
had something to say
about this discovery.
By June 1949, people had begun
to realize that it was not so
easy to get a program right,
as had it at one time appeared.
The realization came over me with full
force that a good part of the remainder
of my life was going to be spent
finding errors in my own programs.
>> That is so true, and
it's something I didn't understand
when I was learning to code.
I thought that every bug I was
introducing into my own programs was
some failure on my part as a programmer,
but
I realize now that bugs are inevitable.
They're going to happen, and so
the important thing isn't to avoid them
entirely, it's to develop a strategy for
systematically getting rid of them.
It's not so much about spotting typos or
logic errors as it is about
building a correct mental model
of how that system works so
that you can find out
what isn't working.
In this lesson I'll show you some
techniques that can help you make
debugging part of your learning process.